but first here in germany officials say
the number of daily new coronavirus
infections has hit a new record the
german institute for national public
health says almost 34 000 new cases were
recorded in a 24-hour period early
thursday that's more than were recorded
at the height of the pandemic's third
wave back in april of this year
the german health minister says stricter
measures are needed for those who refuse
to get the jab
and it seems that that's prompting some
people to reconsider
it's not the latest fashion that's
causing long lines at this shopping mall
in central berlin but the chance to get
a jab without an appointment with kovitt
19 infection rates skyrocketing all over
the country and many vaccination centers
already closed the number of people
dropping by here is on the rise
being my growth i'm doing this because
of my grandparents i want to be able to
see them when the pandemic was really
bad i didn't see them for more than a
year and i want to be able to do
everything again
i was recently on the road with my
friends and we wanted to eat at a fast
food restaurant
but i was kicked out because i am not
fully vaccinated and only had done a
rapid test
i don't want to have to think about it
anymore when going to a restaurant or a
club i can then just prove i'm
vaccinated and going easily
and of course it's important to protect
the elderly
solidarity is important too
not everyone sees it that way
more than 16 million germans have not
been vaccinated
at the same time experts are
recommending speedy booster shots for
people who were vaccinated more than six
months ago
but who exactly should get them doctors
say groups that are especially
vulnerable or exposed to the virus such
as over 70s and medical staff and only
them
we are able to tell from analyzing the
data we have that from that age on the
risk of serious illness increases in
case of an infection
and we believe it makes sense to first
vaccinate the people who need it most
health minister yen span however insists
with the fourth wave in full swing
everybody should be able to get a third
jab
i don't see why people who have been
vaccinated more than six months ago and
want a third shot now because they meet
a lot of people for example should not
be able to get one from their doctor
at the current vaccination rate however
it would take more than a year to offer
a third jab to everyone
so to avoid new restrictions it seems
germany's vaccination campaign itself
needs a booster
well for more on this let's bring in dw
political reporter julia saudelli juliet
two-thirds of germany's population are
now fully vaccinated against covet-19
yet new infections are at record levels
how can that be explained
well we have to consider that this
number that we're seeing of new cases a
record number which we hadn't seen um
it's higher than the last highest record
that we saw last year in december at the
height of the second wave well this new
number might also be due to a backlog in
reporting of cases because on monday it
was a holiday in some of germany states
so we'll have to see how that pans out
in terms of a backlog of cases but
nonetheless the numbers are very high
and are rising and the health minister
yenshpan has spoken of a pandemic of the
unvaccinated because those most affected
by severe cases of coronavirus and those
getting infected the most are those who
are not vaccinated and the head of
germany's national health agency has
said that this is due to a low
number and a slow progress of
vaccinations and because people are more
relaxed regarding rules to prevent the
spread of the virus and what they're
saying is that germany is now in the
fourth wave of the pandemic which is
hitting with full force
the effectiveness of the vaccines yulia
are known to wear off over time does
germany have a clear strategy for
rolling out booster shots
well this is at the center of the debate
in germany right now and health minister
yen span said just yesterday that the
booster shots are not being administered
fast enough and that there is a need to
speed up this process
there have been experts who have said a
lot of it has to do with
lack of communication it is not being
communicated clearly enough how
important it is to get these booster
shots and um how much of the protection
of the
previous doses of the vaccine starts
waning after a few months especially in
older and fragile people
others have said that there is a need to
speed up also the and change the
logistics of the vaccination campaign
for example the big vaccination centers
had been closed and there have been
calls to reopen those again what are the
german authorities saying julia about
the possibility of another lockdown this
winter
well authorities at the state and a
national federal level have said that
they do not want to bring back tough
measures like lockdowns or
curfews but we have heard
german chancellor angela merkel she's
the caretaker chancellor at the moment
through her spokesperson saying that
if the situation in hospitals becomes
serious she can see
more restrictions be applied to those
not currently vaccinated so we'll have
to see what happens in the hospitals and
also what the next german government
might decide
julia thank you very much that was our
political reporter julia saldelli
you